i wish i could look at myself
in the mirror without being disgusted at
what i see i can tell my friends to be
strong
and to love themselves but i can't do it
myself i feel worthless
like i don't deserve to be loved
[Music]
for many young women it's not always
easy to be your true self
kung fu is a new series from the cw
about a badass chinese-american woman
named niki shen who uses her fighting
skills to protect her community
while her friends and family know that
nikki has practiced kung fu the extent
of her skills remains a secret
for now in partnership with the cw we
asked teen girls to share their secrets
and invited other women to read them
to better understand the challenges
these women have overcome
i've been bullied at three different
schools i've begun to blame myself for
being bullied because i think i'm stupid
and weak
i feel worthless and now makes me feel
even worse because now i'm bullying
myself i give all of my self
and love to my friends but i never
receive the same in return
i feel that they all think of me as an
annoyance
is there something wrong with the way i
show my love
i'm gay but both my parents always say
that if their child was lgbtq plus
they would disown them all i want is
them to love me
but i know they never will
i came out when i was in seventh grade
i faced so many problems with my parents
because they grew up
in totally different environments than i
did i did move out
and i did establish my own life in that
time
i was able to kind of understand myself
and then i understood my parents
my parents have always made me feel
insecure about my body
when they remind me that i've gained
weight they hold me to a high beauty
standard and it really takes a toll on
my mental health
these thoughts have made me want to kill
and starve myself
work out until i literally can't breathe
i've stopped being myself
because i don't feel comfortable in my
own skin
gosh i just want to give this this girl
a hug
you know when i would go back to the
philippines or see friends and family
it's just so common to to say
oh you've gotten so fat or you've gained
weight or you look healthy or
you look chunky or every single
variation of that you can think of
if there's anything i could offer to
this girl to help
is to decide when enough is enough for
you
and when you want to say no like this is
like you need to stop you need to stop
calling me fat or you need to stop
commenting on my weight like it's
it's actually hurting me more than it is
helping me
after we took our clothes off i changed
my mind
he got angry i felt trapped and that is
ultimately how i lost my virginity
i haven't slept well since and i still
feel ashamed about it
now i'm too afraid to get close to
anyone i can't trust
anybody unfortunately i
know way too many young women who have
experienced that
myself included and quite a few of my
friends
i know that it can feel really painful
and isolating
and shameful it's not the end of
intimacy for this person
and in developing relationships of trust
and consent
i hope that this person can really feel
nurtured in that when i was 17 i got
pregnant
when i told my boyfriend he told me to
go away and deal with it
i ended up having a miscarriage before i
could do anything
i was alone in a public bathroom because
i was too scared to go to the hospital
since they would tell my parents
i've had a miscarriage and i've also had
an abortion i was
maybe 16 when i had the miscarriage
if you're 17 you're probably in high
school and there's counselors that you
can talk to
you probably have some friends that you
can talk to that you
might not even know can relate with you
because once i told one of my friends i
found out that
she also had a miscarriage around the
same time that i did
there's definitely a lot more girls and
like women out there that you can talk
to
i hate my physical appearance my cheeks
my upper back
my skin complexion especially my waist
all of my friends have a flat stomach
and it makes me feel terrible
i'm self-conscious i worry about
everything from the way i talk to my
personality
i definitely feel every word
on this secret because it's the way i
feel
there's always this standard you know
like of having a flat stomach and like
having like
a thigh gap and you know i don't have
any of those things like
i was bullied a lot for the way i look
um bleed a lot
for things i can't change about myself
like my facial features
and it was during moments like those
where i realized like why the
do i care about what everyone else
thinks about me
i don't know what changed within me but
i realized like that was such a downward
spiral that i couldn't get myself
out of and i need to get myself back up
i've always had the reputation of the
good girl who does
well in school and has a good family
the truth is i've been struggling with
mental health
i feel super alone because others won't
understand
how i can have my perfect life and yet
suffer from depression
i want someone to be there for me but i
don't want to reach out
i understand what it's like to not have
people see you and see that you're
struggling and
i dealt with a lot of depression and
anxiety in high school
and it kind of felt like i was in the
middle of the street drowning and no one
could see me dying
once you find someone that is able to
hold the space for your emotions and
your life
go for it you know it's hard to find
people like that
i got a great scholarship for four years
but i'm not happy
i feel like i just have to please my
family because it's what's
expected of me i've been suffering from
depression stress eating
starving and having anxiety all the time
i'm too scared of what people have to
say if i tell them i want to drop out of
school to find my happiness
it is so difficult to go against
what your family wanted from you i was
a valedictorian salutatorian candidate
and i was applying to go to
military academies and this application
is not some short application you can
finish in two days okay this is like six
months
i finally stood up to to my family and
said
i can't do it i was only doing it
because it's what they wanted you are
not
your grade point average you're not your
s.a.t scores
or the name of the school that you
graduate from
you are worth so much more than that
a male friend took advantage of me and
it all happened because i'm very
soft-hearted
it's been three years and i haven't
healed yet i hate myself because being
so sensitive always makes people use me
i feel like it happens to
a lot of girls um
i was very skeptical
at first you know but this person
really tried his best to make me feel
comfortable and
make me open up and be vulnerable and
after we talked for a while
he kind of just like kept you know
begging
for more and more and it ended up
that he had a girlfriend and he ended up
telling her and the people that i was
around also
that i went into his room and i begged
him to
to do things with me and that if he
didn't that i said i'd kill myself
because i had a um um
i was talking about things that were
personal in my life so he used that
against me
so not everybody's going to be like that
and if you do close yourself off to the
idea of
finding someone or love then you could
be missing something special
but i'd say that you should have time to
heal from it before
anything else it's very important to
heal
i wish i had someone telling me when i
was in middle school in high school that
you're beautiful the way you are you
don't have to change for anyone
trying to figure out who you are and you
don't have to have it all figured out
when you're a teenager you don't
everything around you is telling you
that you're
too much and not enough you're too
ambitious you're too loud or too fat but
you're enough we are told every day what
we should look like what we should think
how we should feel
and the fact that we are in a place now
where we can stand up and we can say
that is not me that is not what i want
to look like that's not how i want to
feel
and i'm going to tell you take it or
leave it there's a lot of power in that
and i'm so proud of all the women that
fought
for us to be able to get here today
thank you to the cw for sponsoring this
episode
and thank you to all the women who
participated make sure to tune in for
the premiere of kung fu
on april 7th at 8 7 central or stream it
free the next day
only on the cw we'll see you next time
you